let me just say something we're talking
about this this election Republicans are
magnificent at one thing that they're a
marvel at losing and they deserve to
lose Republicans deserve to lose you're
in a position that you deserve and I'm
not talking about the establishment I'm
not talking about Fox News though I
think a lot of conservative media has
been entirely about preaching to an echo
chamber and making sure that you collect
those dollar dollar bills not about
getting your ideas out to another forum
that's everything we do is free and
accessible difference of opinion but
they always make the wrong decision and
that's all of you you all bear some
responsibility a majority of you right a
lot of you didn't but let's look up for
example in Barack Obama right in 2012
that was it that was an election it was
pretty important the Obamacare rollout
the Affordable Care Act wildly unpopular
wildly unpopular Democrats weren't happy
with it because the public option wasn't
included of course Republicans were
always opposed to it now it was
effectively a giant kickback to
insurance companies which we now know
rollout was difficult had to be extended
it was an absolute premiums going up
deductibles going up prices skyrocketing
it was wildly unpopular that was the
weak point on Barack Obama think of it
as a video game that's the flashing weak
spot you're supposed to hit with your
laser gun so who did Republicans
nominate they nominated the only other
single person in the history of mankind
not the United States all over the world
to have signed a healthcare mandate into
law the only person to have not done
that the only person who have done that
not named Barack Obama his Mitt Romney
that's who Republicans reign and so he
ran like a sackless monkey not willing
to attack Barack Obama on the one weak
point that could have won the election
that's a huge reason why Republicans
lost that's the pivotal point
here in this election there is one
really significant weak spot with
Hillary Clinton she has the second
highest unfavorability rating of any
presidential candidate in the history of
American politics second highest ever
that's her weak spot why because she's a
flip-flopper she's inconsistent and
people think she's a liar they think
she's untrustworthy second highest on
approval rating ever so all Republicans
need to do is nominate someone with even
a moderately high unfavorability rating
just an average one what do Republicans
as it looks they're going to do they
find and will nominate the single person
with a number-one highest unfavorability
rating of any candidate of all time in
Donald Trump there are so many people
out there right now with Hillary Clinton
with her on favorability rating they are
looking to vote for anyone not named
Hillary Clinton the only person who they
will also put on that list and more is
Donald Trump now the Republicans you
deserve to lose you deserve to lose now
we're talking about this let's get into
the numbers and then we'll get into the
principles of it okay I'm not a
political pundit necessarily but I watch
all of these people and they talk and
they get it so wrong okay the last
election Romney Obama was determined by
about 5 million votes 60 million to 65
million that's what determines that
election if you listen to really
conservative sources like Rush Limbaugh
or Mark Levin they estimate as high as
four to five million registered
Republican conservative voters did not
come out to vote for Romney who even
voted for McCain so they say 4 million
less than McCain skeptics say it's only
about one to one and a half million
let's split the difference and be fair
let's call it 3 million 3 million less
Republicans voted for Romney than McCain
because they didn't think he was
conservative enough what killed Romney
was not the independent vote what killed
Romney was that kid that the cavalry
never came over the hill now if you look
at the numbers that we have Donald Trump
is the one candidate who will have the
highest number of Republicans who
guaranteed will not vote for him he's
that candidate he will have far more
Republicans who will not
vote for him okay so he's starting at
let's conservatively say a deficit of
ten million when compared to McCain or
Romney he's starting at that deficit so
people are saying he's going to get so
many moderates he's going to get so many
Democrats you believe that the guy who's
going into a general with a deficit of
millions based on the polls that we have
available to us you can't throw them out
when they're not convenient in a general
election with the single highest
unfavorability rating in a general
election of all time is somehow going to
magically gain more Democrats and more
independence than any candidate running
since before Reagan that's your gamble
it's a high-risk gamble
that's not inherently wrong right
high-risk gamble you make why Trump
knows this our to the deal if it's a
high reward okay that's a high-risk
gamble it's the highest risk gamble
Republicans can make what's the reward
you get a borderline lifelong Democrat
pro-choice anti second amendment
anti-free speech four bankruptcies
serial admitted philanderer divorcee who
didn't have an opinion on partial-birth
abortion guns illegal immigration was
flip-flopped on that until he decided to
run for election that's your reward
whether he's your guy or not that's your
very very high risk reward and the
reason his supporters the sole redeeming
reason they don't deny that is it's
based on the idea that Donald Trump is a
great businessman so can we've gone
through the numbers
great businessman that's his selling
point
okay let's use the numbers that Trump
used himself okay in 82 he said he was
worth 500 million of course he was
estimated to be worth about 200 million
he said 500 million if he'd have taken
that money put it in an S&P index fund
he would be worth today at the rate of
increase that was I think about over
that course because of the boom in the
eighties over eleven percent twenty
billion dollars if he put it in an
unmanaged index fund and never touched
it twenty billion dollars he claims to
be worth ten billion that's twice what
he claims to be worth now that's what he
claims to be worth okay
the closest thing we have to a third
party now
was due H Bank they put it at 750
million forbes has enlisted about 3
billion donald trump varies based on
many many billions depending on the day
this is a guy who inherited anywhere
between 40 and 200 million dollars from
his father when he got started okay his
business would have done better if he'd
have done nothing with that money also
four bankruptcies and left people
holding the bag so you're talking about
it by the way he sued a publication for
saying that he was worth two hundred and
fifty million dollars twice because he
sued them for what five billion dollars
because he said they were lying guess
what he lost twice in a court of law
why because the court deemed that the
estimation of two hundred and fifty
million dollars wasn't proven to be
inaccurate by donald trump himself he
wasn't able to so he lost that case
twice so again let's recap this you have
somebody who is going into a general
with a deficit of republicans according
to the data of more than any Republican
candidate that we've had in recent
memory probably ten million he has a
single highest unfavorability rating of
any candidate running in the history of
ever run against Hillary Clinton will
somehow magically went over a number of
independents and Democrats not seen in
decades who is a serial philandering lie
about everything candidate who's never
been consistent on a single issue until
the last six months and even knows he's
flip-flopped because you believe he's a
good businessman and you believe he's a
good businessman because he inherited
Luton two hundred million dollars from
his dad and it's very likely worth
nearly half a century later less than a
billion dollars that's your play
congratulations you've not yet been
corrupted by the internet and your short
attention span I know mine went away
with dramatic hamster and then it was
just solidified with history of dance
that guy can really do the ice ice baby
here's the thing you may not know this
is a clip from a full three hour radio
show you can see that full show by
clicking next to me I think there's
something else playing in another box it
might be another short video I don't
know I can't be bothered to do my
research you're still here